good morning so today we are heading to
Long Beach and waiting for Jenna
grabbing us some Starbucks
I just dropped Maddie off at his
babysitter you need to go play with
other dogs today and have a really fun
time we're going to Long Beach for the
Toyota Grand Prix I'm pretty excited
it should be really fun there's also
this really great shave ice place in
Long Beach Sydney and Jenna have been
dying to go to called the fresh shave I
went there when I was in Hawaii and
they're like hey we have what along we
come visit us which is so good thank you
no I know the session are you so good oh
that may be on our list today
[Music]
okay when you asked me where I was I was
in the garage and I ordered the
Starbucks in the night come here
well here's your coffee okay are you
appreciative No tonight is the night can
the feeling hold us I'm not sure you
don't go to your park have a path I've
got nothing I'm just driving live it
$40 day but we're good question I
character then parking
wait wait wait when we play we have in
barrows was that way see if I had money
like yep so Nancy okay what is it that
way then I guess that way the money has
been confirmed that the parking is still
not to be found
receipt way than you two
[Music]
hey don't worry ready yeah I'm also hit
by a cop car he was driving he was
driving on the sidewalk what am I
supposed to do I didn't know he's behind
me silent didn't hear anything instead
of them beeping a lady goes peepee I've
never actually been to the Long Beach
racetrack that I have raped here in
Forza and a lot of you guys like senior
drivers are is terrible I did have a
really incredible camo car leaves I had
that going for me or the baby behind you
brakes here before right I went the game
he is in the game I was not crazy not my
strong point in the game real life on
the great driver and that is Tammy field
on Connor now we've got to find him in
real life oh hey I'm it one more time
but not a dance and got it and and
mother and ha yeah I call you last out
on your birthday yeah we were I wasn't
dancing you weren't dancing over there
well I'm not a star or a dancer so yeah
clearly I don't know if I sure but he's
on it are you want to be in my blog love
me until it's happening right now what's
happening is Connor Bailey is about to
make its debut on Dancing with the Stars
and the finale of the clowny
are you ready we were there are you
going to win today we're cheering for
you me and Jenna cheering squad this is
really important I appreciate it I
appreciate it
would you sign my is okay yeah why not
that's great country
well good luck thank you ready ready for
race day done yeah I blow definitely
tell about the lemonade a pretzel we're
going to get Jenna was eliminated
pretzels we went 5500 two years ago
together Jenna didn't go with me last
year you missed out I had once it off
you did end up on the hunt for lemonade
pretzels
Connors mom's giving us the official for
where to go
[Applause]
[Music]
great start Ben Oh Meghan I'm sooo
nervous I get nervous why you doing here
[Music]
so we're into why I went to play sell
fresh shave and she was like yo we have
a place in Long Beach and like I don't
really go to Long Beach that often but
since we're here for the raisins agenda
we have to go check it out because Jenna
was in quiet and did not go to the place
I didn't make it there nope now we're
here we're going to get it you're going
to definitely want to get the coffee one
I hope they have it it was so good the
dirt squirrel
[Music]
actually off the secret menu
hallelujah holy crap hi Maddie do you
have fun time with your new friends
it looks good let's go home jungle horn
playing back home from the race and
unfortunately Connor did not win at Long
Beach but James did so congratulations
James
you guys might remember him from Dancing
with the Stars on this past season but
now we're home and we're going to play
some Forza I had to redownload Forza 5
and this is my car look at it take a
good look at this beautiful masterpiece
that I created in Forza 5 so I played a
little bit of Forza 5 back when the Xbox
one first came out because they're
basically wasn't any other games so I
was like I either play Forza or Zoo
Tycoon so options were pretty limited or
Dead Rising I think that was also
another one so this is my car look at
those beautiful purple tinted windows
that chromed out front the hood can't
while it's beautiful we're gonna be
playing on the Long Beach course I don't
know what to expect I haven't played
this there I am look at me we are on the
track guys we are ready to race
look at that nice dodge whatever I don't
know what that cars
let's go I've got my little course lying
on I forget what that's called I'm not
sure probably beginner mode I'm such
trash at racing game this is a sharp
turn you're gone
to get around this so I was actually a
perfect turn are you kidding me
ah that was the parking garage that we
parked in that I just passed did you
guys see it
oh god no you'll see it on the next turn
but that's where we parked I'll show you
a clip of us going to the parking garage
and you can see we were actually suited
to
[Music]
I'm actually having a lot more fun
playing this than we thought I would
thought I didn't like racing games but
I'm actually having fun
[Applause]
do I like racing I mean I guess Grand
Theft Auto is not really a racing game
that's more with open world I'm going to
run people over and destroy their lives
type of the game logs green patina what
a break okay I'm in first that's
probably not gonna last I can still
remember probably turned my goodness
even my controllers camo this was a
beautiful track Wow
I mean I was there in person but like
seeing it from the road Long Beach is
actually really beautiful keep control
get control of yourself
get control of yourself to seeing and
your dodge whatever the heck you're
driving get going
do not turn around again like that this
is got to be over soon
let's go perceiving track honestly thank
God I was starting to get a little
nervous
well there we go okay I guess I did I
did better than I thought okay now I
didn't look at my car it is beat that
side boom look at the rim so good nice
look I forgot you could you rewind on
this if you do something but you don't
like okay that's it thanks for watching
I hope you enjoyed this vlog from the
actual long beach track to the virtual
one I had a lot more fun playing courses
than I thought I would my God look at
this car it is yeah hey you know if I
continue playing this game I'm going to
have to get some better cars because you
know nothing against dodge but like come
on I kind of do a little upgrade I'll
see you guys later
hi
[Music]